if we go by Gallup opinion survey what
other countries think of the U.S opinion
of the U.S has dramatically improved
since Biden replaced Trump I think that
matters I I'm not an isolationist so I
think it's important that other
countries respect the office of the
presidency and under trump it was a joke
you know literally laughed at at the U.N
goes to India mispronounces 10 Indian
names and the crowd is just leaving it
it was a humiliation everywhere he went
so I think that's a great it's like a
soft thing that I think is really good
so the the fact that we're no longer
feared is a good thing what data do you
have that we are no longer well that's
not it that's what data is not uh any
data to give I mean how do you know what
it is no but but during by during Biden
is when Russia felt comfortable bullying
Ukraine
[Music]
[Applause]